for his first White House visit as
president elect Donald Trump brought his
brand to Washington DC no president has
entered office with a business empire as
large and sprawling as Trump's
conflict-of-interest is a growing
concern which he is doing very little to
calm he tweeted prior to the election it
was well known that I have interests in
properties all over the world only the
crooked media makes this a big deal
Donald Trump owns golf clubs hotels
office towers and licensing deals in a
total of 18 countries or territories
some are allies some are ruled by
autocratic dictatorships all make the
questionable dealings if Trump doesn't
impose some sort of ethical limits on
his foreign business interests aside
from the White House this is Donald
Trump's other big Washington DC property
acquisition is being pitched to foreign
diplomats as the place to stay and do
business that wouldn't be an issue at
any other luxury DC hotel but when the
owner is about to become president alarm
bells start ringing federal ethics laws
don't apply to the president but others
do Trump could run into problems because
of a clause in the US Constitution that
bars the president from accepting gifts
from foreign leaders so the overall
situation it's like a hostile takeover
of the United States government by the
Trump Organization it's profoundly
concerning Norman Ison was the chief
White House Ethics lawyer for President
Obama he could be in violation of the
Constitution the minute he takes his
oath I don't even know how he can take
his oath when the payments the
emoluments are flowing to his hotel he's
promised in the oath he says I'll defend
the Constitution and as soon as he
becomes president he'll be undermining
it he says Trump's only option is to
sign over control of his businesses to
an independent trust
see who would then sell his assets the
president-elect loves to say he wants to
build a big beautiful wall he needs to
build a big beautiful wall of trust and
the trustee would take the proceeds put
a behind the wall and then buy and sell
in investments that are unknown to mr.
Trump instead of downplaying his brand
president-elect Trump says it's hotter
than ever his solution is for his family
to take over the business I don't know
if it's a blind trust if Avant get done
and Eric run it but is that a blind
trust I don't know but I would probably
have my children run it with my
executives but the presence of his
daughter Ivanka at this meeting with
Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a
raised questions the lines are blurred
Hillary Clinton and the Democrats
brought this up many times and the
American people thought about and they
said okay you know he has he has
interests that that may you know have at
least the appearance of conflict of
interest but we believe this man in his
heart is going to do what best what's
for the country if he violates ethics
rules he should be a hold accountable I
don't believe you will and I don't think
the American people think he will Donald
Trump has to demonstrate that his
priority is serving the public interest
Trump's career as a successful
businessman played a major part in
bringing him to power if it isn't
managed properly it could be his undoing
Amanda Walker's Sky News Washington DC